(applaudissements)
- À droite toute :
c'est comme ça que Liz Truss
a mené sa campagne.
Les baisses d'impôts promises
ont su charmer la base
du Parti conservateur,sss
ont aussi exposé une candidate
qui semblait sourde à la crise
de l'inflation et de l'énergie
qui frappe la Granrereretagne.
Victoire en poche, elle promet
l'audace pour maintenir
ses engagements.
"On lui a reproché de vagues
promesses pendant la campagne,
mais il était injuste
d'attendre plus détails
sur ce qu'elle comptait faire",
dit ce partisan.
Il lui fait confiance.
"Les gens lui demandaientdededee
si elle était premier ministre,
avant même qu'elle n'ait
le poste", dit ce député.
Il ne faisait pas de doute
que Liz Truss allait l'emporter
sur son adversaire, Rishi Sunak.
Mais le peu d'écart entre
les deux candidats, lui, étonne.
L'anciinininistre des Finances
démissionnaire du gouvernement
de Boris Johnson avait l'appui
d'une majorité importante
au sein des députés du cabinet
ministériel. Il faut maintenant
les rallier avec des mesures
d'aide plus généreuses
pour faire face à la crise.
"On n'aura pas de deuxième
chance pour bien faire",
dit ce député, qui soutenait
Rishi Sunak.
Il n'y a pas que les députés et
les ministres conservateurs
que Liz Truss doit maintenant
convaincre. Selon un son
publié récemment par YouGov,
52 % des Britanniques croient
qu'elle fera une très mauvaise
première ministre.
Il n'y aura pas de lune
de miel entre Liz Truss et
les Britanniques. Elle doit
faire ses preuves maintenant.
"Faites quelque chose pour
réduire les factures d'énergie,
lui demande Roger Moyo,
parce que beaucoup de gens
doivent choisir entre
se nourrir ou se chauffer."
Pour encore beaucoup
de Britanniques qui vont
regretter Boris Johnson,
Liz Truss, qui est restée proche
de lui, est rassurante.
"Je crois qu'elle soutenait
Boris, alors je pense qu'il n'y
rarara pas beaucoup de changeme,
mais ce sera intéressant de voir
ce qu'elle fait", dit Fionna,
qui pardonne tous ses écarts
à Boris Johnson.
Elle est prête à donner
sa chance à Liz Truss, tout
comme les dirigeants européens,
avec qui les relations depuis
le Brexit ont été tendues.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
- Je dis bienvenue à Liz Truss
Je lui exprime toutes les
félicitations de la France et
nous sommes à disposition pour
pouvoir travailler entre...
comme on dirait, alliés et amis.
- Tout ça à partir de demain.
Boris Johnson et Liz Truss vont
se rendre à Balmoral en Écosse
pour rencontrer la reine,
trop affaiblie pour quitter
sa résidence estivale.
Lui remettra sa démission;
elle sera chargée de former
le prochain gouvernement.
Ici Marie-Eve Bédar
Radio-Canada, Londres.